a case of illegal dumping is creating a
real eyesore for some people here in the
valley this is happening up in Sunrise
Manor right near Owens in North
Hollywood Mary Jane bellies it gives us
a look at the problem that is pouring
onto the street
as you can see this corner of North
Hollywood Boulevard and Owens is a
sparse area it's become a Target spot
for illegal dumping where garbage is
growing
it's all over social media you know my
neighbors in the area they're constantly
complaining about it mattresses and
couches on the side of the road David
Lewis has lived in this part of town for
16 years he says it's a constant battle
with illegal dumpers who have left their
trash at the site
so this lot in particular apparently I
learned today that the owners out of the
country
so they've had difficulty contacting him
but they say they're they're making
progress which is good to see because
this has been going on for almost a year
and a half where the the trash piles
just continue to grow Andy Cheney is in
charge of illegal dumping for the
Southern Nevada Health District Cheney
says they notify the property owners as
soon as they can public owned lands have
a maintenance schedule cleanup Crews and
things like that that maintain the
property once we notify them they put it
on their schedule versus a private
property owner they're going to get a
certified letter from us out of the blue
with photographs and GPS points
identifying dump piles on their property
Cheney says Property Owners can protect
their land by posting signs and placing
berms he and Lewis are encouraging
others to report any illegal dumping
since it is a health and safety concern
it's not uncommon for people to spend
anywhere from 500 to several thousand
dollars on a cleanup depending on the
extent there's a lot of surprises that
come up everything from used motor oil
to dead animals it's our community we
have to take action to to take care of
it when reporting illegal dumping Cheney
says it's best to include pictures
videos and a license plate number if you
can so they can catch and find illegal
dumpers reporting from Owens and North
Hollywood Boulevard Mary Jane beliesza 8
news now you can report to Illegal
dumping by calling that number on your
screen there it is
702-759-0600 just press option two for
the direct line and you can also report
it online at the southern Nevada Health
District's website we'll post that link
at 8newsnow.com